soit messieurs vous savez que denis
coderre est furieux contre postes canada
n'est pas le seul il ya des citoyens de
la région de montréal qui veulent
intenter un recours collectif contre
postes canada pour avoir mis fin au
courrier à domicile pour projeter de
m'être fait au courrier à domicile
voici ce qu'a obtenu thomas gerber il
est là thomas bonsoir à vue donc
représentant du groupe
le j'avais parlé aux représentants du
groupe du citoyen de l'arrondissement
world dollard des ormeaux
c'est ça et ils ne demandent pas le
retrait des boîtes postales
communautaires lui il veut un
dédommagement financier une sorte de
rente mensuelle pour contrebalancer la
présence nouvelles depuis deux semaines
de ces boîtes la ses arguments et les
inconvénients qu'il invoque d'abord il
estime qu'il y à une perte de valeur
pour sa propriété
il se plaint aussi du nombre de voitures
qui passent que de jour comme de nuit
pour aller chercher le courrier ça fait
du bruit
il dit aussi qu'il retrouve
régulièrement des papiers par terre
parce qu'il n'ya pas de poubelle ou de
bacs de recyclage pour ramasser le
courrier indésirable
et puis il se plaint aussi d'une perte
de vie privée puisque des gens regardent
à travers de chez lui on peut l'écouter
les gens s'arrêtent je regarde à travers
les ma femme qui à la barre d'un surplus
de mettre dehors à la piscine elle est
comme timide un peu l'appui puis
l'alléger tous les soirs depuis qu'ils
ont commencé ça là je vais devoir
commencer des papiers des prospectus de
la cochonnerie kaki les gens ils jettent
ils s'en foutent les voitures les portes
qui claquent
alors ce monsieur il invite tous les
gens qui ont une boîte postale
communautaire sur leur terrain ou au
moins dix mètres de chez eux à rejoindre
cette demande de recours collectif qui
n'est pas encore accepté et je vous
mentionne que tout le monde ne pense pas
comme lui j'ai parlé à d'autres voisins
qui ont des boîtes devant chez eux et
eux ça ne fait pas de différence ça ne
les dérange pas très bien et thomas ce
n'est pas l'avenir la première poursuite
judiciaire contre postes canada dont
vous parliez denis coderre les maires de
villes comme montréal laval longueuil
ont rejoint une poursuite devant la cour
fédérale qui a été faite par le syndicat
des travailleurs des postes et il ya
également une poursuite qui a été fait
par la ville de hamilton en ontario qui
réclamait 200 dollars de compensation
par boîte postale installé à noter qu
hamilton a perdu cette poursuite donc ça
sera intéressant de suivre cette
poursuite citoyenne cette fois ci en
plein contexte électoral merci thomas
jardin au revoir au revoir